v no invités à ivan goa porte parole du
collectif mayouri santé guyane et
yannick xavier secrétaire général du
syndicat union des travailleurs guyanais
c'est notre débat de ce soir
bonsoir à vous deux merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france la
situation elle continue de se dégrader
violemment guyane comment on vous
l'expliqué yves angoy
déjà un bon jour en l'espèce déjà par le
manque de moyens manque de moyens
humains le manque de moyens matériels on
le rappelle que nous sommes mobilisés
depuis 2001 depuis le début de cette
crise pour dire qu'en fait la guyane n'a
pas les moyens qu'il faut pour faire
face à cette crise et dans le reportage
on à pompe qui a déjà plus de lits de
réanimation dans l'ouest guyanais et
pour cause il avait lui lit pour une
population d'à peu près 60 à 100 mille
personnes lui lit de réanimation donc
comment voulez vous faire face à une
crise de cette ampleur vous êtes
d'accord il ya ni xavier
parce qu'aujourd'hui système sanitaire
guyanais c'est un manque d'à peu près
400 à 500 soignants
donc lorsque vous faites ce déficit là
avec la crise qui s'installe le manque
de moyens le résultat lié donc nous
remet un peu surpris que la directrice
de la rs seulement maintenant tire la
sonnette d'alarmé
justement l'inquiétude dans les hôpitaux
ivan quoi quelle est la situation
la situation c'est qu'on est en guyane
comme dans l'hexagone on le rappelle
qu'on doit faire face à une obligation
vaccinale qui est en cours aujourd'hui
depuis le 15 septembre ou en demande au
directeur des centres hospitaliers de se
séparer de personnel non vaccinés alors
que 70% de la population guyanaise
aujourd'hui n'est pas vacciné notre
potentiellement vous avez aux alentours
de 70% de la population hospitalière
aussi donc aussi bien personnels
administratifs personnels soignants qui
n'est pas vacciné nantes alors qu'on est
dans une
ce pandémie alors qu'on ait fait
sanitaire violente et qui a besoin de
personnel soignant au contraire en
demande aujourd'hui aux persos au
directeur et au système de se séparer de
personnel soignant on avait des libéraux
en a des libéraux qui viennent soulager
les hôpitaux et maintenant on fait la
chasse aux sorcières aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir suspendre les contrats de
personnel soignant nord qu'on en a
besoin alors jusqu'où qu'est une chose à
une précision par rapport à cette alerte
qui est bizarrement mise en oeuvre ces
derniers temps par la rs guyane et comme
par hasard la visite d'un ministre sur
notre territoire a à peu près hier ou
sept derniers jours et avait pas plus de
300 et quelques cas supplémentaires sur
le territoire 31 lits de réanimation par
exemple occupé sur notre territoire
d'accord c'est ça les chiffes en fait et
on veut faire croire à des chiffres
d'alarmé des alarmes où on veut faire
croire à des chiffres exorbitants en
janvier 2000 matin nous étions à lui 100
cas par semaine et par jour pour
certains donc la 300 et quelques cas
nous sommes pas encore au plus haut de
la crise est par contre en tire la
sonnette d'alarmé parce qu'on est
incapable de pouvoir soigner
correctement les personnes qui ont le
coup vite comme dans l'hexagone on les
renvoie chez eux avec du doliprane on
attend que ça s'aggrave alors que dieu
pour n'a pas les moyens justement
réanimation de faire face à des
situations qui s'aggrave vous dites
incapables de faire face justement une
situation qui est alarmante maintenant
mais qu'il était avancé ce que vous nous
expliquer justement il ya ni xavier
est ce que tout ça ça donne quand même
l'impression d'un manque de prévention
d'un manque d'anticipation
est-ce que c'est à votre avis c'est
particulier aux territoires d'outre-mer
à votre avis ouais je vais choquer
quelques uns mais nous on a plus
l'impression d'être en colonies en
territoires d'outre-mer parce que vu
comment nous sommes banalisée vu le peu
de considération
vu le peu de moyens qui sont mis à notre
disposition
alors que le président a parlé de guerre
mais nous on se moque des couteaux et
des canifs alors voilà où on en est
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est au même plus
de moyens dans la sécurité civile en
trois mois on a vu arriver à peu près
100 à 150 gendarmes en trois mois on a
vu arriver vers soignies voilà pour vers
le ratio
donc aujourd'hui la guyane c'est
l'image de la martinique l'image de la
guadeloupe l'image des territoires
d'outre-mer ils sont laissés pour compte
et convient saupoudrer quelques mesures
est passée par là un confinement
recouvre veut on faire croire que on
prend en compte la situation du
territoire ils veulent quoi tout à
l'heure vous parliez de l'obligation
vaccinale pour les personnels soignants
alors que justement la campagne de
vaccination elle n'est pas suffisamment
avancée
dans les départements d'outre-mer vous
avez l'exemple de la guadeloupe où un
directeur d'un centre hospitalier
injustement refusé d'appliquer la mesure
comment réagissent les autorités de
santé les responsables de santé en
guyane par rapport à cela là nous sommes
fiers du camp patriotes guadeloupéens
parce que du coup en fait on a ce
problème là dans nos territoires c'est
que beaucoup des directions diète
beaucoup la direction ne sont pas en
fait gérés par des locaux on a des
personnes de passage qui ne prennent pas
en considération comment dire ça les
vraies réalités du territoire et on n'a
pas cette chance lâche d'avoir un des
directeurs locaux qui gère vraiment le
territoire correctement en fait on a des
personnes aux ordres et
n'a pas cette alerte là on fait au
niveau des des trois centres
hospitaliers de la guyane et pourtant
ils sont dans une situation encore plus
catastrophique que la guadeloupe la
guadeloupe aujourd'hui aujourd'hui un
chu ils ont les moyens ils ont plus de
lits de réanimation où on annonçait fin
2020 250 soignants et il l'a dit mon
collègue tout à l'heure 250 camions en
moins sur le territoire on est sûrement
aujourd'hui à peut-être 400 soignants en
moi sur notre territoire et on a des
gens qui ont mis en place des notes
d'information n'a la rs café une
conférence de presse pour dire qu'ils
vont faire des contrôles et que pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de sanction mais
la loi c'est parce qu'elle dit donc la
directrice de la rs guyane n'a pas été
auprès des instances pour aller chercher
le décret qui permettent au territoire
aussi bien la guadeloupe la guyane la
martinique la réunion nos territoires
d'être sous couvert en fait d'une
obligation de soins qui leur incombe
aujourd'hui on est on veut mettre en
oeuvre l'obligation vaccinale mais on ne
veut pas vraisemblablement soigner les
personnes qui sont malades sur notre
territoire parce que comme en allant
faire avec le co vite on a des
programmes et des opérations urgent donc
on a affaibli certaines personnes et
après on s'étonne qu'il ya des morts
aujourd'hui depuis janvier on compte sur
notre territoire une augmentation du
nombre de morts mais mais en 2020 alors
qu'il n'avait pas le vaccin les gens
mouraient voir sur notre territoire ils
mourraient mois sur notre territoire
parce qu'il y avait encore des
protocoles de soins parce qu'on faisait
on faisait en sorte un de soigner les
personnes de plus qu'à les vaccins cetc
soit et vaccinés soit est mort alors on
le rappelle la guyane qui enregistre un
record de morts et d'admission
réanimation en fait jour
est-ce que donc on imagine que dans les
populations c'est inquiétant justement
il ya ni xavier comment elles réagissent
les populations les comment réagissent
les guyanais est ce qu'il ya un
sentiment de panique qui s'installe
mais pourquoi paniquer parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est neuf pour ses neufs
pour vous mais nous on le vit depuis des
années ou en un système de santé
défaillant
donc c'est triste mais ce n'est pas une
alarme parce qu'en fait on sait qu'on
n'a pas les moyens de lutter aujourd'hui
c'est ça le constat c'est que la
population guyanaise c'est on n'a pas
les moyens dans les hôpitaux pour se
battre donc on sait pertinemment que
aujourd'hui une fois rentré à l'hôpital
c'est pile ou face
le directeur de l'hôpital de saint
laurent du choc a dit qu'il met une
cellule en place au permettent de trier
c'est à dire que des patients qui vont
arriver selon l'âge maxime n'est pas
vacciné comorbidités ben ils choisiront
il a annoncé donc on est déjà face à des
criminels qui vont choisir et dire on le
droit de bio de moi mais ça c'est notre
quotidien malheureusement alors un
quotidien vous semblez d'écrire une
fatalité il ya le ministre quand même de
sébastien lecornu quitte les outre-mers
donc qui est à cayenne depuis cet
après-midi ce message que vous portez
est ce que il peut l'entendre ce message
à votre avis ivan boire
normalement il devrait longtemps
normalement ils devraient comment dire
ça surtout trouver des solutions mais il
est là depuis hier soir en fait sur
notre territoire et ce matin il a visité
le centre hospitalier de référence et on
n'a rien entendu nos élus ont interpellé
le ministre de l'outre-mer depuis
plusieurs semaines depuis plusieurs
jours a aujourd'hui on n'a toujours pas
de réponse est laide et vous l'avez dit
le nombre de morts continue à augmenter
continue à faire son chemin donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'on a besoin nous en
guyane c'est pas de gens vaccinés nous
avons besoin de gens qui sont négatifs
au vide nous avons besoin de moyens
humains nous avons besoin de moyens
matériels et les moyens humains on est
en train de les stresser on est en train
de les mettre en difficulté puisque des
libéraux par exemple ne savent pas s'ils
vont être payés à la fin du mois et ça
fait pas normal et pour le personnel
hospitalier ils ont soit sur la tête un
éventuel contrôle ou quand on va les
contrôler mais on va les devoir
suspendre le contrat parce qu'ils sont
pas vaccinés
70% de la population aujourd'hui en
guyane n'est pas vaccinée nous sommes
pas comme dans l'hexagone 60% de la
population est vaccinée dans l'hexagone
aujourd'hui c'est le contraire bien donc
on met à mal le système de santé oms met
à mal comment dire ça là la capacité de
soigner et après on nous dit les gens
meurent ici la crise non merci les gens
pourraient ne pas mourir en fait yannick
et xavier en 10 secondes votre message
au ministre avez-vous trois maires qui
est présent soit rangée à des entités il
y à des entités qui revendique et qui
travaille pour l'amélioration du système
de santé qui ne sent pas à l'encontre du
système de santé il faudrait peut-être
prendre le temps de les écouter de les
rencontrer et de ne pas faire une
politique de l'autriche merci à vous
xavier secrétaire général du syndicat de
l'union des travailleurs guyanais et
merci à vous ivan agua porte-parole du
collectif mayouri santé un guyane